hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot I
am like my Hardy and I am honored to be
here with Joseph Aras nice to meet you
yeah it was I think it was five years
ago when I first talked to you when you
were just about to release brother as a
tail to son Zach yeah it's funny because
he contacted me I was actually quite
surprised that you wanted to do a what
is it called like an interview we have a
feature release yeah no it's a feature
story and I saw your story and I wanted
to talk about brothers and tail the two
sons and obviously like from Starbreeze
studios and yeah it was kind of like
your breakout videogame hit because of
course you've directed film before that
and then wanted to go into video games
originally from Lebanon then you moved
to Sweden and now you're kind of all
over the place right now that you've
made brothers and now on March 23rd
you're about to release a way out yes a
game that caught a lot of people's
attention when you first showed it off
because of the cool ways that plays with
co-op and foot screen and whatnot right
yeah we're gonna get to play it today
and then we're also just gonna chat the
whole time great to have you and it's
good to be it's like going full circle
like we said before yeah definitely I'm
looking forward to it okay cool so this
is a way out I'll let you lead us yes
so cuz you made it so first of all we
are two split-screen co-op only so what
you do is like you can't play the
locally online it will always be
split-screen however you play it okay so
we're gonna jump in like two hours into
the game I don't want to spoil myself
for you yeah great the spoilers don't
look so much okay so if you press X star
to join gotcha
it's very hard to demonstrate our way
yeah but we can start right like so
you're gonna have it if you go too right
so you gonna have a short presentation
of the characters on the left you have
Vincent and on the right you have Lee
you have some kind of background for
this kind of like in the beginning of
the game you and your friend choose
whoever whoever you want and once you
decide but let's take I take Vincent not
because I'm on the left side okay I'll
be leo yes yes and they have different
personalities I will show you later they
react differently to the you know to the
world and it's not like one shoots ice
and other shoots fire yeah this is a
cinematic co-op experience where you
actually are playing in character it's
not a drop in drop off oh okay so that's
very important that's the whole lot
that's why the idea came up because I
wanted to play a co-op game that wasn't
not just that well that's interesting
his brothers we were talking about this
earlier it's almost like the opposite
you had to play a single-player but I
won't spoil anything because he have
brothers tell two sons I highly suggest
you could do it but toward the end it
starts messing around with like whether
you're playing single-player maybe like
a little bit of co-op elements etc but
this seems to be the opposite has to be
co-op right I like to mess around that's
oh yeah I know we know so what you see
here is like I would say maybe two hours
into the game we just escaped the prison
and we're about where we have no
Sounders we have to pretend that we're
here okay yeah yeah so and just to
remind you like we are small in the
company I know many people have liked
mixes up with triple-a titles which is a
compliment of course yeah but we are a
small company working very hard for
three years I'm insanely excited and
proud for what we have come come up with
so yeah let's go up here so I'm gonna
show you this section we're gonna go up
the thing is like it's way better to the
whole idea is to keep talking with your
friend or what's going on I kind of
carry this react and stuff but now you
should be like you can play with the
developer and like yeah I'll show you
the way I'm walking off yet I get to
play with you that's dope so even like
small stuff like this like it's like so
if I help you up cool ok so then yes if
I out there even those much cuz do you
have different kinds of air with you it
would have been the opposite the scene
would have been a little bit different
than what they say whatnot so your
screen would have gotten wider and not
no not that is what they say like for
instance alright ok personally it takes
Lee it's a small detail I'm just saying
like the amount of content this game for
every NPC in every reaction they react
differently also how they solved how
they solve it but once we see like
players play in the game it comes
natural to them they just go and
interact them yeah it just happens and
then it says to say these two characters
I mean I don't want to go in too much in
the story but they don't know each other
at first
now after that they are in the prison
you escape together you start to get up
a relationship that's the whole idea
with the game that's you as opposed to
brothers which obviously like as you can
tell by the title yeah all right let's
see you know if we can I'm assuming
we're trying to avoid these guys yeah ok
and there is a point where I'm showing
you this scene because again the way I
was real hard to demonstrate because
this is the way out right now but it's
gonna be changing something else so if
you go left and I right so we can take
I'm gonna take this guy out okay let's
see then you want me to get this guy
yeah taking on all right all right I
take him out here yeah and you can look
at find inside like oh [ __ ] is in but
it's fine if I swear on this right yeah
go for it
all right I got this guy okay perfect
perfect he's uh he's knocked out oh [ __ ]
how many more two more okay all right so
will you add let's see here you are
coming up the ledge right here okay take
this guy out
oh [ __ ] there's another one here a lot
of thick two different ones that oh no
no no no I get lose I'm the developer
man oh my god don't know that would have
been like hey I gotta take a girl okay
area is down so let's walk here that
we've been very like yeah you made a
dramatic I know you're just trying to
create suspense huh for real I was about
to lose I'm telling ya let me get the
gun I'll go guys I go for the left
everybody okay go go go boom
all right cool yeah I like the dynamic
split-screen I mean that was the thing
that got people's attention in the
trailer right like it was kind of how
it's shifting and there's actually like
it was on the same screen but they were
in two different locations as well yes
yes definitely and the thing is like
again that that's what I want today
wouldn't show you the gameplay it's very
hard to master at this game like even
this scene feels different when you play
it in assert like from the beginning
yeah it's real dogs just rocked in but
let me just get to there's a guard up
here as well okay I'll take it
Shango follow you or go this way now
there's a lot guys that way there yeah
yeah let's go this way all right but you
know like also split screen yeah I miss
them but the idea behind this like the
the biggest challenge this game was like
how to tell a cinematic story experience
with a lot of gameplay obviously because
I like activity of game because this is
not your typical story game really just
like go it's more of an action adventure
yeah addict title you know and that was
what's cool about brothers because not
only was it I mean it told a cinematic
story but it also kind of played with
the gameplay to tell the story right
everybody everybody's played it knows
that moment or one of those moments but
exactly is that something like you're
aiming for maybe not something similar
but kind of the same ideas like using
gameplay to tell the story in this game
I don't want to spoil anything but they
play it from the beginning to the end
okay and when you can see what I want to
say so I'll take the right guy you take
the left here all right catching up let
me know when you're ready
so the thing is like this was one of the
childlike how did you tell about two
characters with personalities in
different stores at the same time so
that was like one of our biggest
challenge yeah like how do we solve that
how do you make it fresh and unique the
whole time so you're ready here yeah all
right one two go
so why I want to show you this chapters
like this is it yanking down guards
that's the only place you do it in a way
out you're never gonna come back to it
again okay we'll be one further on here
but it's more of an animation that
translates transit you into the car okay
the reason why I show you this is that
no when you look at this you're not
gonna walk around in bushes and take out
guards yeah that the things you've seen
here that's what it only happens in the
game okay and that is what a way are the
changes itself all the time to keep it
fresh and unique and all the experience
and for me it's not about how the long
the game is I think the long the game
will be around maybe between six eight
hours okay no six I'm yeah but at the
end of the day it's like it's important
it's fresh and unique all the time and
yeah and yeah we have something else
here I mean the story is it's it's it's
a story driven game that you can't
affect the story some house but we have
some stuff I call them like decision
moments and they affect in the gameplay
sometimes like for instance this case
and this is like I said two hours in the
game these pop up and come into the game
when the characters know each other more
so there are different personalities one
guy is very afraid of heights and is Leo
who's my brother my big brother you know
get in for free low-budget style yeah
wait wait what do you mean it's your big
brother it's my big friend my real big
brother
Wow but I do all the mock-up in the game
so I'm a face and the voice interesting
I guess a Leo looks a little bit like
yeah yeah okay go but they have a way
bigger nose than me that's the only boy
yeah so just to get back to this so what
we have here you can either choose to go
over there did you see there it says
Vincent's way yeah so you have to decide
so we have talked in the couch or
whatever we say like what do we do we go
under over and it will be different like
anything we go under the bridge will be
something if you go over will be
something else okay
in this case let's pretend that we
decide I'm going over okay so we have to
decide on two other so we have to go on
the sink well that worked out as I hope
in terrified of heights yeah you have to
old hold square oh yeah otherwise we
can't and you will have no art moments
coming like okay okay so you go and you
can't hear the sound but it's like we
take them out take this car and cross
the bridge oh yeah okay so it's like
more of a brute-force approach yeah you
say that yeah so so that's what I mean
with the takedown so that's not really a
taker because he transits into that to
that but here again to show you like how
the game changes here's another scene
that he was here so here you can either
like gonna go slowly or just barrel
through oh yeah if you want you want to
go hard then go for the speed outputs
whenever you want I like the role
playing on the car I'll do that
yeah sorry so we find on hind in this
case I like I have to stay here and
otherwise I get caught and I could also
mean something also sit in the in the
driving seat and drive and stuff like
that and there will be off obviously
different audio different dialogue the
pen is so that's one of the problems I
didn't really like them out of Compton
for whoever like goes in front then
whoever takes the front sure all right
now I don't know no sauce here yeah all
right
yeah I mean you see the subtitle I say
you know what's going on with you all
the sound man I know you see now we have
play but say if you see if you go left
or right with your controller you see
the car you see the tires and you have
like control anyway all right he's my
kinda says Drive so go see yeah yeah
okay keep to the left to the left oh
yeah
well things really want south yeah
exactly
so obviously going under the bridge
would have been a different thing but
then the day ends up in the same so the
divisions are mostly like almost
sometimes different game play or they
are in game play so you get a different
situation or what's going ok so you
better be ready right now
oh man I think look my looks good that
almost looks like triple-a yeah that's
okay crash I want another you said forty
people yeah we started with ten the
roundup before that's nothing much
nothing it's like crazy with the team
cuz you said brothers was like they're
12 people yeah yeah something like that
yeah
oh but you have to find a way to say
money like wins I do all the mob cap all
the stunts like my brother's the face
and then and voice of Leo why not use
your face you hear my English man I
sound like an idiot brother speak better
English yeah yeah tell me kid oh [ __ ]
okay maybe we should concentrate here we
go
press X to the bottom are you waiting to
catch up yeah I'm waiting I could up not
well it goes full screen yeah go we have
to like own this it's actually fun
failed states here if you don't hold it
it's also like what a lot of what does
impale me on a rock no it's like sure
you just fall down okay alright so your
idea of fun is dark
alright so I'm gonna pause here and jump
to another place to give you a like oh
yeah actually can ask me more questions
yeah no I do want to ask you about
developments so this is under EA
original so and and obviously like we
were talking on something so many
publishers get a bad rap whether it's
through micro transactions or whatever
but you're saying like your relationship
with EA has been super great right it's
not a problem are all they're super
super you have to understand one thing
look I am that I am Who I am like look
at me I'm not the guy they're like have
scripts or what I say what it should say
and not say I said what I wanted this
how it is the candid yes so candid what
is that candid yeah yeah not scripted
you can't be censored no no I can't
so so the thing is like and I told this
immunity it so
and they're super support they're
separate they can't even change the
color of like if an app but if they want
to make a greener yeah I can say no to
that
so nothing so it's only been supporting
Afghanistan wanting the originals deals
they have with these like indie
developers that they're given hundred
percent of the income to the developer
so they're not making a single dollar in
this game yeah and at the same time
they're still helping me out with all
the PR news so there's no money involved
you know yeah and and even whatever have
whatever happens in the future whoever I
work with is gonna be the same with me
because this is why I am I'm a
passionate guy I believe in what I do it
fine if I um it's like passion is what
drives me you know I mean I'm ready to
be homeless so whatever you don't know
like I live breathe this game I don't
care if someone even told me like here
you take ten million dollars make a
single play I would say no yeah
definitely say no because you already
made a single-player game right yes that
too but it's like you have to fit the
vision what the game is about that is
for all publishers and yeah of course
publishers [ __ ] up sometime not only all
that all publishers does that they're
human beings they [ __ ] and take a pee
like everybody else you know it's a big
company you have Cheryl there's a lot of
reason for that you know but well the
mistakes but for me and hey let's be
super good like optimist means
supportive very nice people and now the
game is gold it's almost on the way out
right March 23rd on the way out good oh
no oh I did not mean that but I'm
speaking up we have we want to do
another scene yes that's cool I would
jump back no no I wish oh so again to
jump again if you press X got it I'm not
kind of leaving you hanging all right so
some people are swap not a people not a
good idea swap but I think naturally
when we see people play this naturally
they they like they they play and they
really connect with them yeah they get
stuff yeah you're which I'm very happy
about Leo incent is that yes yeah come
inside yeah so I'm playing Vincent and
you're playing the leo
I got your brother different stories and
on yeah that goes on I saw you were you
were we went to jail for murder but not
me oh you made the background story yeah
if those are true so right now is that
we're outside and you know and here's
another scene where like you know that
they're hungry you know they gotta eat
food and serve it and then why should
they say this is not a scene when you've
been in prison escapee Allah Allah when
you come to this scene you kind of feel
a freshness to it I'm sure we're
actually gonna gonna go fishing together
like co-op fish we actually do it here
again and that's what it makes sense
that's what sometimes like I think in
some games with the repetitiveness I
don't like it you know I think it's
better to be like fresh and unique
especially for us for a story for a
story game yes you need to be like
engaged and focused throughout the whole
entire time
it keeps the pacing up - oh my god helps
apiece - apiece yeah exactly and that's
also which I mean artistically we're
changing the the like sometimes I get
surprised myself like how did we even
pull this off and also being able to
play it online with spits green I mean
it's yeah it's it's way harder than one
thing because the product there is a
reason why split screen games are not so
popular today because it takes a lot of
like work to do them especially the in
hand like this because they're like how
do we tell the story like you can't do
this stuff like you're doing single play
games where you go to trigger trigger
cutscene because here the other one
where's the other player and is he
looking at the other players yeah yeah
so there's a lot of like tricks that you
can't do when you do a game like this so
speaking of triple-a I just noticed my
like the bottom of my pants got wet when
I went through that stream yes with
driving we have as much as we can huh I
remember the first time I saw that
you're not trailer for a game maybe it
was like uncharted 2 or something I
thought what it was but that blew my
mind yeah yeah now you were used to it
doesn't blow it anymore yeah but maybe
I'll take it for saying yeah like for
trip Triple A games you take it for
granted I exact point it does that is a
nice like triple-a touch so here they
find a camp that's you know they want to
fish okay yeah and then again like the
characters talk all the time and like
it's been a lot of fun I mean a lot of
work or a lot of fun I mean to write
this dollar I mean I I wrote the whole
game but I've had this like script
doctor what I'm gonna call it the helps
me with English cuz yeah yeah yeah you
know I mean it's good for being from
Lebanon in Sweden you understand me yeah
so I do want to ask and maybe this is
something that might spoil it so uh bear
with me but obviously brother's a lot of
it was inspired by your life events like
I was telling we were telling people I
did that I wrote that feature when I
interviewed you back five years ago or
something when the others about to come
out and you draw from your own life for
this game I mean I know at some point
every person really like anything that's
really I think it's more towards that
it's it's more towards that than to it's
actually is from my life okay but so
just to like see they can craft the
spear and I can help you out so I can't
just go this so what we do is like we
walk around there's actually I mean I'm
not gonna show but there's an assumed
and connected to brothers here so I
recommend check it out it's actually
quite cool one see so right here like
saw how it be else if you go to the
water like a spear and so because it's a
co-op game so we do some co-op fishing
here and again these moments I love this
calmer moments so if you go into the
water I'm happy if you go to the other
side so yeah we got audio in the studio
now so you can I can verbally embrace
this along with the audience yeah so
you're supporting it I'll just stand
still I guess the thing because the
amount of content for a scene like this
it's a lot of work for a small scene
that maybe take five minutes to play
yeah but I think it innovate it's you
got it time yeah nope oh [ __ ]
all right let's fissure fast [ __ ] oh
you come on I'll get them to their they
don't want to I go forward a little bit
oh is that it yeah yeah yeah we got it
here we go it looks good my rostov as
well so
you just put this over the spit and cook
it as yeah and then you're gonna help me
get your fish and then that's it you put
you find some twigs to start the fire or
use it and then and then and then you're
done pretty much with this see there's
no gap there's only one time okay then
we're gonna jump to another one here
okay and so like as you're playing the
game a lot of the dialogue tells a story
right between the characters you're
saying characters a lot of different
mechanic if they are mean we do have
shooting in the game okay but it's only
that wouldn't make sense in the story
but you wouldn't call it like a third
person shooter but we have like third
person shooting one would cover me and
service but it's only that when it makes
sense okay but now you understand what
it means by explaining the game yeah
hard to showcase like what is it like
what's the game mechanic or whatever you
want to call it all right I'm gonna jump
here I want also show Dan there are a
lot of chapters oh yeah
I think my initial assumption was gonna
be like three or four hour game no no
it's more it's more all right let's go
again so right now we're gonna jump in
maybe four or five hours into the game
okay
now without spoiling the details in the
story my guy Vincent is have is having a
newborn baby and you're following me so
we actually go into the hospital to to
see my newborn kid and they're there and
you know escaped I mean the prisoners
obviously so some but what I wanted to
show is also another thing because a way
out is it like moments where it's full
of action and sometimes it's low-key
moments like you saw with the fishing
yeah but there definitely will be like
high-stakes moments as well I call it
that high stakes like yeah yeah yeah
high tension high tension yeah stuff
like that this is yeah this is cool like
it's a more of like a life story I guess
I got going through yeah it's all about
building the relation between the
characters like who they are and then
and of course slowly like their story
like you understand more and more about
it that's going on them do you do they
clarify where this takes place or is it
just a 70 someone northern kind of
fallen yes okay guys like so whatever
we're likely for instance like so all
the NPC's in the game are uniquely
animated for every character it says
unique stuff and this is only options if
you follow me here for instance I like I
talk for instance to these but whoever
you talk is gonna be unique
and these are not just the animation
system the tics and this is like so and
if you just say so I talked with them
and you have like a small like choice
where you can like whatever you know but
if you go and talk to them now they
would say something different to you or
the opposite yeah
so that's I did that's also optional if
you want to do sound like comforting
this kid right now yeah yeah yeah but
but leah has different personalities so
Vincent is like a different kind of guy
they're very different personalities but
there are also other things like if we
walk here it's Benson more nurturing
what's naturally I see more like caring
and kind of yeah yeah you'll see their
character traits in the beginning and
you kind of like choose from that with
your co-op okay but you know so it's a
back story right yeah small stuff like
and they also understand when you see
the story in the cutscene and a small
log here first this is a magazine where
there is mugshot of them because and if
I interact with that he will like
covered with the book but if you do it
you will do it differently so so again
like the characters reactively it's it's
it's like there's a trash can right that
yeah yeah there's a throw but I would I
wouldn't have done that wasn't something
different yeah so again if you're the
kind of guy who likes to talk these are
like written in quite funny ways I
recommend people talk to them PC they're
quite fun if you're interested oh yeah
yeah game and like a lot of these like
spread out meaning it's the reason we
can sit down here if you want like come
with me here we go question connect for
yeah why not we can just play around I'm
gonna let you win now sits it's it's
going faster okay this also optional of
course not like you have to do this area
so you can win this one I'll just go
straight out yeah just I thought you're
gonna block me not pretending you're
lying I just take it once it's here for
okay we'll see here so you can like boom
yeah so it's like and you're bad at this
yeah so we have like for instance like
dart baseball we have a lot of these
small pebbles on our cake machine like
it's set in the seventies it's very
retro like oh yeah what kind of do you
have any pair like any games that we
might now you probably couldn't use it
right it's actually games are made up
yeah but it's just that fun stuff if the
players wanna here comes another way
like I call I get this
in moment or whatever and until now you
know the character does I don't really
want to show too much of it there but
we've been showing this you got an idea
sir to wanted convicts on an elevator
with a security guard like a police
officer and there again it's up to us
like so so this guy obviously recognizes
because you know we're on on the mug
shot yeah and stuff like that obviously
you see leave your character yeah maybe
you are like that aggressive short time
for guys maybe I like to think of it now
okay alright so here again like it's
again to keep the tears talking on car
so it's lit Leah's way or Vincent way
doesn't matter what do you want you want
to knock him out yeah yeah alright let's
do it so it's also like such a like
smoked flavors like this it makes it
Vista would have obviously solved it
different like this so I'm gonna show
you one one thing here also very fast
also known as well Leo's muff handed so
he's different yeah in that way - that's
because I'm left-handed you are okay
yeah both the reason and that's the
opinion on this game like all the stunts
all the fighting I've done myself as
well pictures I mean so here's another
one from the stuff you can balance here
on this one but I like this more man if
you wanna life like it's always sunny in
that was that okay oh man oh I see yeah
after balances you see the score up
there so we have these small stuff we
see like players and we let them play
this they have a lot of fun with these
small meaning again so so again let's
back go back to our camera I'm gonna
jump to the last thing we're gonna look
at yes okay fascinating question while I
load this cool yeah so my so you said
you started out you're getting a new
office in Stockholm yes
originally working within dices office
yeah but we're not working with them
share also just like internet with toast
base just office base yeah I mean I wish
though they were very skilled but they
you know so like assuming the game this
game's cold is come out March 23rd the
fact that you're moving into a new
office soon you know like hopefully
suggest you're gonna keep making games
after that's right I love making yeah
yeah yeah from film director at the game
director yeah
alright ok let's jump to another so what
I want to show you now it's like it's
pretty much the same thing but later and
this is like because obviously there
escaped prisoners that's how you say so
your police come to the hospitals you
have to and this is almost like a co-op
scene we're in a full screen instead of
split screen and sometimes it goes
threes we said play around a lot like
work to this 3/3 screen full screen so
much' but this happens only also only
here so I'm going to show it to you now
so we are chased by the cops and and and
lead characters outside and I was inside
somewhere else like with my wife and
stuff that's why we were like on two
different players yeah so we'll step out
for like a cigarette or something not
really but Oh
first the cops are there as you see
coming so i yeah i'm controlling vincent
now here I go I walk I'm a I run so you
[Music]
[Applause]
see here and this only is like this here
I go with it you see the camera goes on
and then like goes to the o'james and
now you're controlling alright and this
will go out throughout the whole
hospital in one shot
ok that we think like unique for every
everything that goes online we're gonna
play a while and I'm gonna show you like
what goes on yeah I'm very proud of this
scene dude or it's like the like yeah
like a long take like I mean yeah
there's a lot good the whole scene will
be like la I also like that yeah because
Leo like his personality he's also just
running right into cop he's dead of
trying to party he doesn't care he's
like oh man
he don't give a [ __ ] so you see the
camera continues here and then this is
super cool yeah and obviously you have
to have different failed States at every
stop blah blah blah is like wow it's
like good thing there's no patient on
that yes
all right
and it's so nice to see the game finish
at last
yeah yeah they're doing development it's
like it's so nice to see like done
alright alright alright okay if you just
continue that the Tories will walk out
continued our yeah that door walk this
way if you want no not that you just
went there gotcha okay
I think more like leo going straight at
it yeah yeah yeah you know it better
when you're playing him yeah go oh dang
[Applause]
what on earth are you doing
no man that must've been terrifying for
him he's the one that's afraid of
heights right yes but he don't have a
choice but yeah it like makes sense yeah
yeah the height thing is gonna come back
in the game yeah yeah I mean there is I
so here again you're gonna play a scene
that it's for you for Leo only that goes
on maybe for 60 seconds I would say it's
like over 300 nations that's just for
that scene okay and we only use it there
okay at least it's from a production
perspective it's kind of crazy but I
think for the experience is very
important sure so now so here we go and
you say huh you see how the camera is
like doing different stuff well not
right now we're going to LA that's
awesome
I like that that's like a did you play
Nier automata last year like that kind
of does that goes camera yeah I think it
only goes on for these seen that that's
it that's awesome
oh [ __ ] well brawler yeah get out of
here you really seem to all right oh man
damn they feel good these shots right
yeah
it's cathartic okay
all right let's watch Dennett lamp and
this actually me and the friend of mine
of his life that are doing all the more
power really your friends someone
getting beat up yeah do you know that
worked out for you yeah it looks like
you went through a few friends for the
seizure actually anyone like I did so
much cookies mocha like might anal and
mighty that might not take or is it
gold-tone Nana yeah yeah yeah God like
you know angry it went away
yeah a lot went away but God offer I
don't know what to say oh yeah yeah
alright so again this will continue on
and I'm not going to show any more so
yeah super so I like to stop the camera
here awesome
that's all that's JIT that's where yeah
I wanna show more but it's again it's so
hard to showcase this game and you will
have like that last change cold bikes
and well you know do you have different
stuff but I think this is like the most
fair what I mean
for a case to shovel way out you know to
get an idea what's going yeah I had a
lot of fun
yeah sorry but I gots me just make sure
to play with someone I mean yeah I
prefer your plaything couch it's it's
totally ok playing online as well but
the experience I think will be better in
couch and that's that's that's also like
cool because like couch co-op has been
kind of like you mentioned like it's
tougher to do but it's also just been
going away because it's like so many
games are made to be online co-op coops
easy to do what is it about the couch
co-op that's just so it's hard for my
awesome Emily from a technical
perspective you have to like draw two
different like because you have to take
down the the graphical fidelity and I
think of those stuff you have to think
about especially in a story game because
the pacing of their like how do you pace
the store had to keep the players focus
on the story yeah I'm in the coop game
which is I think it's an underestimated
thing like because I think you can tell
really great stories in co-op yeah
because when we look at a movie or look
at a play or whatever I mean we
experience stories together why not in
games as well yeah so that's what I try
to keep pushing the boundaries all the
time like was it hard initially when you
talk to EA like to say like I want to
make a couch co-op specific a mean of
course like there were questions like
should we have seen you play blah blah
I'm like no it's not gonna happen
target okay with it yeah I don't like
that you know I'm like you know either
this way or the highway I don't care
like if it's not the way I wanted to be
that's not gonna happen
Rozier called that because of your
successful brothers are dead like the EI
originals program in general I think
they were cool with that because it's
Excel a brother buzz off of course this
was like the second game so there may be
like suspicions but they trust they
trust division yeah it's just the
unknown now they're seeing the result as
well yeah this is how it is whoever
people whatever like brand or whatever
published you are at if you see that the
developers are delivering I mean look
I've been sitting with the top people at
EA but these are guys that are
passionate about games you know they
love games but here's the thing when you
have a company with shareholders a lot
of this stop you can't just oh let's
make fun they have to make money as well
and I mean I wouldn't like to be there
you know but it is what it is and
sometimes you do like you take some
decisions that go like it's not so good
but they're they guarantee there will be
no loot boxes in games I do that's for
sure yeah hundred percent you know it
will never happen I rather be on the
street yes yeah ESRB today is officially
gonna say like in-game purchases
included on boxes now all right well
yeah I think it's pretty vague but uh
but you don't like those I don't like
those at all I think it's better like I
mean it's better to have to buy the game
and get you know guess what you know but
here's the they make scenes that you
don't see like when I was young and I
like bought game on Super Nintendo it
was like a $60 game you play them for
six are you like Wow
today you want everything yeah this ball
is like you want everything in the game
it's almost like you know along with
today's game is like you want all the
food on the table
yeah and but you only eat this but you
still want it there it's like you have
to understand this is so much work
behind making this pan so I think there
has to be an understanding on both sides
people have to understand of games when
they cost 100 150 million dollars you
can't just all we want this this this
you know there has to be ways of like
making it fair I mean the games are
actually cheaper today yeah it doesn't
make sense look at the prices of like
you go to the movies they're going up it
goes like yeah like with inflation a
Super Nintendo game would have been
crazy expensive right yeah
we have to be more campus compassion
understanding your tongue and stop
what's going on here because at the end
of the day I think everybody wants to
have better games at the end of the day
but of course because we live in a
system where money is like we can't just
say [ __ ] your money and we have to think
about that as well yeah I'm sure you do
that money houses yeah every paycheck no
I don't take my paycheck no just kidding
but not one single dollar is going to ei
for this game and there still has it
supporting me 110 per call to Hays light
it's awesome forty people in Stockholm
yes that's great and March 23rd the game
will be out yeah yeah Xbox one ps4 is
for PC PC any switch plans it's ok it's
hard but not in the plans right now but
in the future you start making it the
switch wasn't even not alright yeah okay
Chloe but it's not impossible
yeah and then if people watching if you
haven't played brothers a tale of two
sons for whatever reason go play that
that's on XBLA PSN or just XP you can
find it it's a fantastic that's a
single-player game only but for very
good reasons as you'll find out once you
play through more of it but thank you
everybody for joining Joseph always a
great time yeah it's good to see you
you're going and you're off to London
tomorrow and then the Germany
jet-setting showing off a way out yeah
it's probably around the world and feels
good probably to have a game almost
honor a super happy but I'm so proud of
this game I feel like I'm so sure about
this game it's crazy I mean people like
seeing me as very confident but here's a
different I'm very confident division
but it's extremely extremely respectful
from the creative aspect it's not like
organized do this I question everything
try to like when I say with the design
team always like how do this this this
this this like there's a there's a
there's a hum I'm humble towards the the
was it called the the handcraft over
yeah yeah for sure I'm very cocky and I
believe in the vision I I'm excited for
it and that'll be March 23rd everybody
thank you for stopping by check this out
and thanks for joining Joseph and I and
hopefully I'll get to see you around
again sometime soon anyway the next game
or after way out
outbut anybody anyway thanks everybody
for joining march 23rd a way out and
then in the meantime go play brothers a
tale of two sons if you haven't yet and
we'll see you around
[Music]